[Music]
hey
i'm alex and today i'm going to show you
how to make my grandma bonnie's
famous recipe for dream cookies i
remember these cookies being
the absolute perfect cookies just like
my grandma bonnie
so when i think about my grandma these
cookies immediately come to mind
they were her signature recipe and one
of my
favorite treats growing up these cookies
are similar to a short butt but they are
a little bit different because they have
a secret ingredient
that ingredient is baker's ammonia so
baker's ammonia is great for getting
really crisp
cookies and crackers which is why it's
sometimes
used today so it's kind of like the old
school baking powder i guess it makes
sense that my grandma used it
the only downside of it is its horrible
smell
i'm not kidding it smells really bad
don't smell it
oh you want to make sure you're creaming
the butter and sugar together long
enough until it gets more fluffy in
texture
all of the other ingredients in this
cookie are pretty classic and i wanted
to find a special way to honor my
grandma bonnie
and other special women in my life if
you were to look up like the definition
of a grandma it would be my grandma
bonnie she's just the cutest person ever
grandma bonnie exemplifies exactly what
it means to be a strong woman
she's someone who is hard-working she
loved what she did she made time to
raise her
family and she made some bomb cookies
too
what's so special about these cookies is
how delicate and light they
are but still crispy and buttery and
just
they're the best when you're shaping
these cookies they're actually gonna be
pretty
small my grandma specifies that the
dough should be no bigger than a walnut
very specific grandma you can pop that
dough ball right on a greased baking
sheet and then
use the back of a measuring cup and
press lightly into the ball
of dough
[Music]
now it's time for toppings my grandma
would always put
three little chocolate chips right in
the center of the dough now it seems
like there's not a lot of surface to
work with here
but just squeeze them on i feel so lucky
to have a job that i absolutely love
but i wouldn't be here if it weren't for
all the amazing women
who encouraged me to chase my dreams now
these cookies are pretty tiny but that
just means you can eat a lot more of
them
i love celebrating the strong women in
my life and women's history month is
just an extra excuse to celebrate all
that girl power
there's nothing like these cookies
they're rich and buttery but still light
and crisp ah
brings me right back to grandma's house
i know my grams is watching this right
now and i just want to say i love you so
much
and i hope i made you proud this one's
for you grandma
so legend has it this was actually used
to wake
women up if they had swooned
trust me it smells that bad hi i'm maria
and this
is my recipe for aquarium cookies
so i was looking on the internet and
found this really cool cookie called
shakashaka cookies shakashaka is
onomotopia for
shaking noise in japanese so when you
shake something and make noise that is
shakashaka
the person made two cookies glued
together and
put sprinkles inside so when you shake
it you can see the sprinkles inside
moving and it was very cute the recipe
dough
looks very complicated they used a
special kind of sugar called palatinos
which is not sold in regular grocery
stores so i wanted to make it but
make it very simple so everyone can make
a home
that's something i always wanted to
include in my video that's something
everyone can make at home that's the
great thing about tasty i think
and making this cookie was very fun i
made this video for tasty junior
initially
and i had the opportunity to work with
kids
it was very fun to cook with little
girls especially the child
actor i walked to it she was so
impressed
she told me i could be a chef in the
future and i should open the restaurant
and it was very cute and sweet i was
thinking
maybe i could use strawball candy and
melt it there is also another cookie
called the stained glass cookie
which is very popular
so i use the jolly launcher instead of
the special sugar
and put two cookies together with white
chocolate
so it tastes better when i was reading
komen i saw some audience said
jolly launcher is too hard so if you buy
into it
you might break your teeth but when you
bake a jelly launcher
spread very thinly so don't worry about
breaking your teeth
you won't break your teeth i'm looking
for you
[Music]
this video will become viral and i saw a
lot of people make it
i also saw some people made it for a
bake sale
and it's a great feeling when someone
actually make it and have fun with it
i think also shakashaka cookies is a
cute name
for japanese cookie but if you translate
it it's become
shake shape cookie which is not so
catchy
it was our general manager ashley who
was sitting next to me
and said oh that looks like an aquarium
so that's why i named
it so don't be afraid of breaking your
teeth
it's actually tasty kids love that and
you can customize it you can put love
letter in
it and make it fancy make it fancy
hi i'm alex and today i'm going to show
you how to make my cookies and ice cream
dome cake
[Music]
so this recipe i came up with based on
two things
one i wanted to make some sort of a dome
and
two i wanted to use oreos on the outside
to make a really cool visual
so i knew this recipe would naturally be
cookies and cream flavored because i was
using the oreos but i wasn't quite sure
which middle of the thing
i wanted to do could you done a
cheesecake i could have done an
ice cream cake but i decided to go with
ice cream cake because it was kind of
new
and also i just really love cookies and
cream ice cream cake that's my favorite
kind of cake
it's what i have on my birthday usually
fun fact
so i melted down the cream center in
order to put it back into the ice cream
base that we're gonna make
which i might add is my favorite part of
the oreo
fun fact another fun fact this video is
full of fun facts
so the base is made out of more like a
whipped cream and the sweetener connects
milk
and it still freezes up and holds up
like an ice cream would
it's just a little lighter i would say
less like creamy
than an ice cream would be
[Music]
the crushed up cookies will go in there
also when you're whipping the cream you
want to make sure
you get it to the point where it's thick
but don't whip it too much because then
it'll separate
so based on the size of your bowl it
might vary
how many cookies you put in the actual
bowl itself but don't worry
just put them in until they line the
full bowl now some people might want to
line their bowl with plastic wrap in
order to get
the dome cake out easier but you
actually don't need it it will pop
out on its own the tricky part about
this recipe was when i was testing it
sometimes the cookies would float up and
not stay
in place so the batter had to be thick
enough to be able to hold the cookies
down
then once you make your ice cream face
you'll dump that
right on top of the cookies and spread
it evenly to cover all the cookies
this isn't like a traditional ice cream
this is more like a frozen mousse kind
of thing
but it's super delicious and then super
easy just pop it in the freezer and
wait until it's done you don't want to
pull this out early because you will
have a big
mess and also you just really want to
make sure it's frozen solid
so you'll be able to pop it out of the
bowl easily just flip it over
on some sort of a board and wait until
it kind of
loosens up and it should fall right out
and then you'll have this beautiful
oreo lined ice cream cake the most
important part of this was making sure i
nailed
that beautiful outside uniform layer
and to say it looked pretty cool
also what's nice is that the cookies
kind of soften up because of the ice
cream
so you'll be able to cut into this
pretty easily
[Music]
i think this recipe is great for like a
kid's birthday party because
what kid doesn't like ice cream cake and
also it's so fun
looking make it for your birthday party
whether you're
three or ninety-six i'm sure you'll
still love it
hi i'm brie and today i'm going to show
you
how to make my recipe fall
multi-flavored
skillet cookie
so this recipe was kind of assigned to
me by alden
so he made a multi-flavor sheet pan pie
video
and we as a team wanted to see what else
can we make multi-flavor i wanted to
make something easy
like i didn't want to make each flavor
from scratch
so i wanted to make one cookie dough and
add it in different flavors
using brown sugar is very important in
order to give the cookie that chewy
texture
that i like and also using a little
white sugar
helps giving a crispy texture it's a
good to combine balls
it's important to use two type of sugar
to make this american style cookie
i feel like chocolate chip cookie is
very unique to america
i feel like this chocolate chip cookie
is a little bit rustic shape
each individual cup gives a different
shape and kind of
i don't know like i feel like it's
imperfect but this
imperfection make it perfect
we kind of came up with simple flavor
combinations that everyone likes
like chocolate chip cookie and peanut
butter
and white chocolate macadamia nuts which
is something that's underrated i think
i think it's the best multi-flavor
skillet cookie recipe out there
i don't know how many out there
i used parchment paper to bake so i can
take it out
and transport it to a plate but if you
just want to serve in a skillet you can
do so
you don't need to use the parchment
paper each cookies
next to each other based on how well
their flavor profile combined
and of course everyone wants to eat the
middle part because
you can eat whole flavor so each of six
different flavors all in one cookie
[Music]
and also i cut it in a pea seed so you
can enjoy different flavor combinations
like
chocolate chip cookie with peanut butter
cookie and a white chocolate macadamia
cookie with
double chocolate cookies
[Music]
and i think this cookie does a good job
of capturing a lot of different
characters
it's difficult to make imperfect perfect
cookie
like if you have american chocolate chip
cookie
it kind of has a crack and chocolate
chip is sometimes not evenly distributed
it may have a dent somewhere but it's
cute in a way
a whole imperfection makes a great
cookie perfect
it's not something you can intend it to
make it that way
but it happens that way but it's perfect
in the way
not sure if you get it i feel like i'm
talking about
cookie philosophy i don't know i think
you just try it
make it and maybe you understand what
i'm talking about
[Music]
that's what alex do we're good
okay
[Music]
you